Wow there's so much space
we gotta zoom in that's better so today
I'm gonna be unboxing something that's
pretty exciting because I've always been
you know an iPhone girl clearly yes I
know we're counting down the days the
times of this year when the iPhone 8 7s
whatever it is they're going to be
announcing will be announced whoa oh God
essential lorem ipsum dolor sit amet
textual a pict minute so this is
the essential phone and I'm going to be
unboxing it today for you I know it's
been out for a couple of weeks now they
sent me one and I was out of town so I'm
just seeing it now so I thought hey why
not I'll unbox it and check it out I'm
kind of excited about this because I've
seen a bunch of people unbox them do
reviews and most of the reviews are
pretty good sounds like yeah I'll check
it out I'll take a little gander what's
in this box
but you compare some phones here I've
got my samsung s8 and my iPhone 7 so
let's open up the box still or sit Amit
I'm already real into this this is like
the braided cord so it's like a cloth
type material instead of the usual type
of cord that we're used to Oh baby
charging brick very nice and our USB c2
3.5 millimeter jack most of the reviews
were like hey there's no headphone jack
and guess what that's not new news to me
I've been living with it for over a year
now I sip it over a year we've got a
nice little SIM card just Brit card you
Smith's printer have spread let's take a
peek at our little essential baby boy or
girl engineering sample not for sale
okay I'm assuming this is just a review
unit because the back didn't have text
although I'll tell you what if that is
the case that's pretty cool it has a
nice weight to it
if you want to talk about smudgy I'm
gonna destroy this with my smudgy hands
anything else is here like a cloth
what's this
Oh a little SIM card remover very nice
there's a dog outside barking very very
loud I guess let's turn this on however
I Android one of the things that I've
read that I'm really really loving about
this phone a lot of phones come bundled
with a bunch of their own crap on it
like not just basic stock Android it's
got all kinds of random samsung apps and
all kinds of things to tend to bog down
your phone whereas this is just super
basic like it's just got what you need
here's our little startup screen Alexa
go the SIM card tray is located on the
bottom right edge of your phone use the
sim card ejection pool alrighty it's at
the wrong hole now that's the right hole
you the heck is this Oh what have I done
I thought I broke it the typing feels
really nice on it it's a nice feel real
fast
alright we're signing in I'll add my
fingerprint my fingerprint is added
setting up Google assistant ok Google
what I like what that was fast
I mean that'll off my phone just super
quick with my thumbprint fingerprint not
fun you're so smug II I'm so sorry
little phone I did this to you
it's kind of cool was it has this little
magnetic back here so you can add things
on to it kind of modularly
so let's take a picture definitely my
best selfie work now let's try doing a
little video test this is my office
hello there's there's you
and there's you there's that camera and
we're testing it out hello it's me now
let's do slow-mo and see what that looks
like there is a slight bit of hesitation
but to be fair in the background this is
updating all of my apps and this is like
the first time that I've used it so I'm
assuming that that's probably why so
this is now being shot with my iPhone
I'm in the middle of editing of this
video but I wanted to give you a
comparison between what the back facing
iPhone looks like and the essential
phone now let's hop to the slow-mo
[Music]
Google assistant hey girls hope you find
what you need and get things done if you
need help just ask what can you do
find me a YouTube video of iJustine
dancing yep that's your girl I J maybe
let's watch a fresher videos you guys
know if you've been following my channel
or every other channel covering Apple
things the iPhone 8 will sort of have a
similar look to this top bar this little
notch right here the camera will be cut
out so I think a lot of people have it
speculating like oh what's it gonna look
like with programs are running around
and I think this is pretty much what its
gonna look like
here's our camera and the screen wraps
around the camera but it's kind of cool
because everything just sort of
integrates very nicely into it now it's
time for a little slow-mo montage of the
essential phone
[Music]
so I decided to take all four of my
phones outside I've got a pixel phone a
Samsung S 8 plus an iPhone 7 plus and
are essential phones I'm gonna take some
photos and do a little video test and we
can do a side-by-side comparison and I
wonder what do you guys think which one
is better what picture do you like the
best
what video quality do you like the best
I'll also be testing out the
front-facing and the back facing camera
and let's see what we can see here we go
we've got all four our phones recording
now this is the back camera so let me
know what you guys think you are the
pixel you are the s8 and you are
essential you are time for the
front-facing video test we've got all
four cameras recording now this looks so
weird it's so strange
hi Samsung s8 that's you this is our
Google pixel phone over here we've got
our central phone so what do you guys
think so judging by all four of these
which one do you think looks the best
idol oh now time for our photo
comparison first up is the iPhone and
it's so hard to tell the differences
when you're just kind of flipping
through these now we've got our pixel
phone and it looks like it seemed to
focus more on that middle succulent as
opposed to the entire picture being in
focus and here's the Samsung at this
point uh I don't even know what am I
looking at they're plants last but not
least we've got our essential phone let
me know if you guys see the differences
and here they all are side by side what
do you think which one do you like
better here's our front-facing selfie
camera these are untouched
I didn't adjust any colors or anything
so if you were to post this on Instagram
directly from your camera roll with
actual hashtag no filter what I liked
the most about the Samsung picks on the
central phone is it has a much wider
angle lens the iPhone as you can see is
a little bit more zoomed in fingers
crossed that there will be a wider angle
lens on the new iPhone 8 well that
escalated quickly this really was
supposed to just be a very simple
unboxing of the essential phone and then
I got curious how does it stack up
against the other phones that I
currently have and to be completely
honest with you I'm not really sure
judging by the photos in the videos that
I shot in this video specifically I
would say and I've kind of shook the
Samsung probably would win over the
iPhone as far as the video and the photo
quality but that's not to say that that
happens every time because sometimes I
will be using my iPhone and it takes way
better photos and videos and the Samsung
so I feel like a lot of times it's
circumstantial so depending upon what
situation you're in a camera will
perform differently so what's the best
phone for you I don't know if you're not
a crazy hardcore obsessed person that
worries about these stupid little
mundane things that all of us tech
people do you would be perfectly fine
with any of these phones obviously this
goes without saying if you're an apple
or an iOS fan then clearly you're gonna
pick the iPhone I am probably always
going to choose the iPhone over Android
because I love the Iowa
but if you're an Android fan any one of
these phones will probably be perfectly
fine for you what I do love about the
essay is I really do actually like this
size a lot it's a little bit thinner and
taller the screen is incredible
especially having the edge to edge
display and it curling over the side of
the edges it's beautiful
one of the things that I love the most
about the pixel is it had the
fingerprint sensor in the middle in the
back the essential phone also does
essential phone he's a really good
looking phone the screen is very clear
very crisp and I like that they were
trying something a little bit different
here with the magnetic back display the
iPhone it's my baby man I'm so stressed
out this actually really stressed me out
a lot more than I thought it was going
to see if I had to rank these phones in
order from one to four
obviously I would go with iPhone because
I love iOS and I just seeing so what do
you expect and I feel like it is gonna
be kind of a toss-up between the Samsung
and the pixel phone but I would probably
put the Samsung just a hair above the
pixel and then the essential slightly
below the pixel I'm just gonna end this
video because I'm stressed out now I
can't deal with this let me know in the
comments below what you guys think
because I don't know
[Music]